with a population of more than 20
million people Dhaka is a mega City and
the economic Hub of Bangladesh the
rapidly growing economy has led to high
demand for land but it comes at a
considerable cost to the environment an
estimated 70 percent of its wetlands
have been lost to unplanned development
in the past two decades
Hawkeye used to have canals and wetlands
all around it now they no longer exist
it's all concrete many people have moved
from rural areas to the city
Three Rivers and circle Dhaka but
they're polluted and the surrounding
forests are gradually disappearing as
the city limits expand environmental
experts say in many instances land
Grabbers fill up Wetlands with waste and
sand then they get a lease agreement
from the government and gradually build
commercial and housing projects on it
the process eventually legalizes what
starts as something illegal
Urban migration is also increasing as a
result of climate change more people are
migrating to Dhaka from low-lying areas
which are prone to flooding as sea
levels rise
homes got washed away by the Sea so I
moved to Dhaka for work one study
suggests 2 000 people move here every
day authorities say there is a shortage
of adequate housing infrastructure and
water and waste management systems which
is increasing the spread of diseases
yes land Grabber yes land grabbing is a
problem in the canals and River are
narrowing and losing their death due to
The Dumping of pollution which causes
flooding the government has taken the
initiative to fight against land
Grabbers and those who occupy parks and
other green spaces
urban planner said development projects
need to be regulated if the government
wants to reclaim wetlands and expense
sustainably
there are laws and a plan for the
development of the city but these are
hardly implemented or enforced by the
city development authorities District
administration or law enforcement
agencies
the U.N says DACA could become the
world's fourth most populous Mega City
by 2030 but few believes it's prepared
to handle this growth tanvi chaudry Al
Jazeera Dhaka